yeah and part of that grind is like epic
failures or epic bombs on stage and yeah
every every comic i ask on here i ask
them a story of getting
booed on stage or just epic failure i
know you've been in like memphis and
you've gotten a fight
you've had to give people back their
money in some show is there one that
stands out that you just like i'll never
forget this moment you know the toughest
one for me
like i gotta you know admit probably the
toughest one was in new york and it was
for like an industry showcase and i was
there perfect
and it was one of them you know one of
them ones where you feel
like you're going to try to write jokes
for
the audience right so you're going to
try to change your
yourself to fit them and i bombed i mean
i walked up and bombed and it was like a
horrible feeling
and steve was there actually harv was
there and he literally walked on stage
after me and
i mean it's this corporate environment
he can stay
out of the audience and they were dying
like they just loved the fact that he
was just real like and he was just like
and he was like you know you sitting
there and you're like i'm just one of
the funniest dudes in the world blah
blah blah
just letting them have it and that's
when he was like don't go didn't he just
basically don't ever change man just do
you
if that don't work then it don't work
but don't try to fit in like you know
so that was one of the most valuable
lessons i took i mean of course
you took some hells in many different
times you know yeah we all have
yeah it's it's it's the business you
know it is that so
but uh it was one that that that
particular lesson was one that i was
like okay
i can use that one yes all right and
we're uh we're running out of time here
so appreciate your time and even doing
this before your show here
for sure just in closing here is there
any other closing advice
you have for comedians over your entire
career you can kind of
bestow on them you know the main thing
is always try to get as much stage time
as you can i mean a lot of times
people just want to make it and they
have a couple of jokes and they
and they kill it whenever they go on
stage and they believe like that's all
that it takes but
really the more that you sharpen your
knife your machete whatever it is that
you
when you're on that stage and have that
ability to walk out there
uh is something that i you know always
recommend that people just
and you know don't try to make the money
first you know try to
try to be great at what you do first you
know and then even to this day i mean as
you can tell
i mean you can hear from the roar of
laughter in the background i
have a tendency of putting really sharp
comics on in front of me so that i
have to go out there and put in the work
because these guys
you know that's what happens you can get
you can become a pro and get a little
lazy and
and have the expectations of fame but
when people spend their money they want
to laugh and they want to laugh for real
and so
i try to put myself in a situation where
you have to go in there and do the work
like it's guys these both henry and jj
these dudes are
they out there throwing rocks at the
crowd right now like
so but uh but that's it i mean just stay
encouraged stay working stay in your
mindset
and try to stay free of uh you know
independency trying to
like write things and be true to
yourself and look for the comedy and the
humor and the things that happened to
you in life
hot breath